what are you gonna do today napoleon
whatever i feel like i wanna do gosh
napoleon dynamite was one of my first
movie obsessions which i didn't quite
realize until i found home footage of me
and my sisters where i mostly just quote
the movie
tina come get some ham napoleon dynamite
has definitely stuck with me in the
years since
so i was delighted to find out that my
fellow chicagoan and film critic hero
roger ebert gave the film an abysmal 1.5
out of 4 stars there's a kind of studied
stupidity that sometimes passes as humor
he writes and jarrod has his napoleon
dynamite pushes it as far as it can go
and roger ebert is not the only one who
feels that way most people do like the
movie but it's not universally loved by
any means many reviewers on imdb called
the worst movie they've ever seen and it
has an unusually high number of one out
of tens and 10 out of 10s compared to
other comedies from the same time
according to imdb's metadata napoleon
dynamite is as polarizing as some of
cinema's most divisive movies which is
all the more baffling since the movie
isn't political arthouse or
controversial it's a pretty by the books
lighthearted high school comedy so why
is that why is a simple movie like
napoleon dynamite so divisive the answer
is more complicated than you may think
it's actually so complicated that data
scientists have given the phenomenon a
name the napoleon dynamite effect
[Music]
as the majority of my viewers know the
internet today is powered by
recommendation algorithms and back in
2006 netflix was trying to improve their
own at the time the streaming service
offered 1 million dollars to anybody who
could enhance their recommendation
algorithm by 10
according to a new york times article
from 2008 when statisticians tried to
predict which movies people would like
napoleon dynamite was the most difficult
of them all there was almost no way to
know how someone would feel about the
movie in other words napoleon dynamite
broke the algorithm this phenomenon
became so well known in the statistics
community that the napoleon dynamite
effect has popped up in academic
journals to describe any item that adds
a lot of uncertainty to a model so
figuring out what makes napoleon
dynamite so unpredictable literally
became the million-dollar question the
new york times article gives a simple
answer it's because the movie is quirky
the movie does share stylistic
similarities with other quirky eccentric
films like those by director wes
anderson both napoleon dynamite and wes
anderson movies love awkward blocking
stylized wide shots and silly editing
sequences he's as skinny as a pencil as
smart as a whip and possibly the
scariest man currently living you got
shocks pegs
lucky
but napoleon dynamite still feels
different the movie has much weirder
less relatable characters some critics
find napoleon very unlikable and i do
think it takes more work to find the
charm in the world of napoleon dynamite
than it does in the world of wes
anderson so while it's true that
napoleon dynamite is quirky i think that
sells the napoleon dynamite effect short
other quirky movies around that time
period lack the same level of
divisiveness i think the true answer to
the million dollar question lies in
something deeper it's weird that people
don't talk about aesthetics in cinema
when we describe a movie we tend to talk
about its plot characters or setting we
spend a lot less time on the movie's
aesthetics how it feels its tone or how
it caters to a certain taste and that's
in part because aesthetics are hard to
describe but aesthetics often have a
huge impact like when snow white and the
huntsman and moonrise kingdom came out a
month apart and because the films have
different aesthetics nobody noticed
they're the exact same movie but it's
like a girl runs away from a strange
dynamic in which there's this tension
with the blonde evil woman they both end
up meeting this boy scout huntsman who's
an outdoors guy they're afraid of the
woods but then they become attracted to
each other and have a slightly strange
sexual encounter that then brings them
into an eden
all the while they're being pursued by a
troop of small men
who hate them at first but then sit
around the campfires and end up helping
them and rescuing them and saving them
because these movies have such different
aesthetics it doesn't matter that they
have the same story they feel like
entirely different movies so story often
gets lost inside a strong aesthetic
which is especially the case for
napoleon dynamite
[Music]
many critics of the film claim the movie
has no plot and even i remembered the
movie more as a series of vignettes than
as a coherent narrative but that could
not be further from the truth you know
what movie is actually most similar to
napoleon dynamite rocky both star a
talkative amateur performer who gets
beat up and can't entertain a crowd they
both get an opportunity to compete
against the flashy popular guy and they
prepare with lots of training sweating
and a montage
then the underdog performs in the big
event and gets a standing ovation both
movies end exactly the same right after
the big performance the hero reunites
with his shy love interest as the movie
fades to black also both movies feature
lots of animals have a strong sense of
location
and people drink raw eggs
many critics use rocky as a classic
example of the hero's journey but that
framework can just as easily apply to
napoleon who actually undergoes a big
transformation in the movie at the start
of the movie nobody has napoleon's back
his grandma abandons him kip won't pick
him up from school and uncle rico
sabotages his relationships when he
visits rex cuando he realizes what he's
looking for no more flying solo you need
somebody watching your back at all times
in a rare moment of vulnerability
napoleon reveals he wants that from
pedro so you got my back and everything
what
never mind over the course of the film
napoleon earns that respect by helping
pedro become class president he learns
that for someone to have your back you
have to have theirs but this hero's
journey was completely lost on many
viewers and that is the power of
aesthetics we understand rocky's journey
because the film has a serious gritty
tone so it's natural to notice his
progression and his desire to make a
name for himself all i want to do is go
to distance and many viewers including
me didn't notice that same inner story
in napoleon dynamite it's not like i
cared about the movie's plot when i was
eight years old i just liked that
napoleon talked funny good morning
people can get some dinner and that's by
design the film doesn't motivate the
viewer to root for any particular
outcome in the same way that a movie
like rocky does it doesn't have the
swelling movie score or dramatic
symbolic moment that portrays napoleon
as a classical hero it instead has a
flat objective portrayal of life in
idaho it doesn't tell the viewer how to
feel and the lightweight tone and
over-the-top performance by john heater
disguise his epic character arc so the
movie may have a classic plot but it's
most famous for its uniquely weird
aesthetic one more off-putting than a
wes anderson film but the movie didn't
become a hit just because it was weird
then it probably would have ended up
just another niche indie movie napoleon
dynamite connected with lots of people
because it had a fresh combination of
the weird and the conventional you can
find napoleon funny when he makes up
outlandish stories to try to sound
impressive and you can also root for him
when he finally does get to accomplish
something meaningful napoleon dynamite
became a hit because it broke the
expectation that weird movie aesthetics
must have a weird plot and classical
movie aesthetics must have a classical
plot and i think that's the same reason
napoleon dynamite broke the algorithm
the movie is hard to categorize some
people simply don't resonate with the
conventional story and get turned off by
the goofy aesthetic but those who do
resonate with it absolutely love it and
if humans have such an unpredictable hit
or miss relationship with the film then
of course an algorithm would too
napoleon dynamite bridges the gap
between the indie lover and the casual
moviegoer but it's also not the kind of
aesthetic and story combination people
are used to it's harder for a viewer to
make sense of napoleon dynamite compared
to movies whose story matches their tone
and that phenomenon made the movie a
statistical risk the netflix algorithm
couldn't predict how someone would feel
about such a unique combination and
media companies don't want risk in their
algorithms they want movies that they
can reliably predict movies with a
risk-free story cast and aesthetic of
course there's still plenty of room for
amazing creative movies today but as
algorithms take over our lives i wonder
if we'll ever miss out on the next
napoleon dynamite because the algorithm
didn't know who to recommend it to or
maybe the next napoleon dynamite will
just get siloed into a specific indie
niche instead of getting discovered and
adored by a large mainstream audience so
i'm hoping we keep valuing word of mouth
and other people's recommendations
because that opens us up to finding the
next great thing that breaks our
algorithm and in that spirit i highly
recommend napoleon dynamite and i hope
this video was a good recommendation for
you this is pretty much the worst video
ever made napoleon like anyone can even
know that if you want to take more
control over your algorithm and help me
out in the process consider hitting the
subscribe button below i've got more
videos in the pipeline that i think
you'll like and i also really really
want a million subscribers so thanks for
watching and thank you to my patreon
supporters i couldn't do this without
you